probier mal dass wir probleme richtig
noch mal ein bisschen mehr hallo etwas
wieder und herzlich willkommen bei einem
neuen video
ich hoffe natürlich euch jedes hut leute
heute habe ich etwas ganz besonderes vor
habt also es dreht sich mal wieder wie
in letzter zeit öfter oben ich versuche
halt mal wieder zu kochen ich muss jetzt
gerade mal ein bisschen leiser reden
weil meine freundin des audi chefs
gerade und dieses bisschen krank und der
fall gesagt jo alex media nicht gesagt
johanna ist so was sagt ihr nicht jo
alex nochmals nein sie meinte dass sie
hunger hat daraufhin habe ich gesagt
okay entweder ich bestell was oder ich
koch was und ich habe aber auch gesagt
dass ich mache dieses video drehen
sie weiß aber nicht was ich für video
mache deswegen ganz kurz die video idee
ich habe im kühlschrank einige
abgelaufene lebensmittel die sowieso
bald abgelaufen waren
und ich war gerade noch einkaufen und
habe es gibt in ihrem supermarkt immer
so körbel da sind abgelaufene sachen
drin und von diesen abgelaufen und
sachen habe ich ein paar mitgenommen und
ich werde ihr essen kochen auch getränke
und so und alles ist abgelaufen
das ding ist natürlich das ist immer ein
mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum also das heißt
nicht dass sie verdorben sind oder so
wir schauen einfach mal nur ob sie da
irgendwie was schmeckt oder so oder ob
ihr das komisch merkt ich gehe aber
davon aus so ist ihr schmecken wird und
dann werde ich auch sagen dass alles was
sie gegessen hat abgelaufen bis also das
soll so die video design
ich finde das eigentlich männer
interessant wir schauen auf ihre
reaktion ist ja eigentlich aktion nichts
verwerfliches kann ich jedem von euch
empfehlen wenn ihr mal im supermarkt
seid euch auch mal was abgelaufen ist
oder was halt an dem tag abläufen
mitzunehmen ist halt noch halb so teuer
kommt mal kurz mit in die küche
jetzt kann sie eigentlich auch wieder
laufen also wenn was abgelaufen ist
kommt halt immer dieser sticker drauf 50
prozent billiger 89 cent das ist halt
wirklich schon seit vier tagen
abgelaufen 24 cent diese vor 30
abgelaufen und das hier gestern
abgelaufen
okay dann haben wir hier noch wurst wird
das ist einfach schon am siebten
abgelaufen aber es ist noch nicht
schicht oder so deswegen werde ich es
auch mal verwenden und eine sache die
ich extra aufgebaut hat ist dieser käse
das tut mir echt leid aber ich kann mir
vorstellen dass sie das nicht schmecken
wird das ist die challenge heute und
wenn sie sagt dass mac täglich sagen
hier sofort l stoppt nicht weiter ist
ihr wisst bescheid aber gute idee oder
ein fall dass dafür erst mal daumen nach
oben und weitere ideen in die kommentare
freut mich und jeden tag um 19 15 neues
video und grüße an die bremse die welt
ist kevins darauf angreifen
also ich würde sagen das riecht auf
jeden fall noch gut
wir haben doch bestimmt auch noch eine
mutter hier die abgelaufen ist oder
sieht man das so kann übrigens futter
aussehen wenn die lange nicht mehr
benutzt wurde und leute seid mir wird ja
nicht böse bringen den kochs geld ich
weiß ich bin nicht der beste
also ich mache hier gerade erst mal ein
paar abgelaufen
bekanntlich kann den namen die
aussprechen ob glock ist möglichst genau
also ich mache hier gerade so ein paar
genau hieß da seid bereit haben glaube
ich abgelaufen und dazu würde ich dann
einen sandwich machen mit käse auch
komplett abgelaufen und dazu gibt's dann
noch die getränke auch beide komplett
abgelaufen
ja und das ist dann das menü für heute
ich weiss ist jetzt nichts aufwendiges
so aber besser als gar nichts die
parallele oder
tanzen war es richtig ist an die sich
jetzt fragen an extras kostet eigentlich
für ein zeug das passt auch gar nicht
zusammen das weiß ich natürlich aber es
handelt sich bei allen sachen und ab
gelaufen und hätte ich jetzt irgendwas
dazu gekauft das wäre nicht abgelaufen
gewesen mal mehr habe ich nicht gefunden
hier zum beispiel noch mal kurz als
beweis 16 07 2009 10
damit ihr das auch glauben also wenn man
sich die toten so anguckt sieht
eigentlich bin ich
okay okay leute das recht ein bisschen
eklig
der käse ist halt schon echt alt also
man sieht das ja da kommt jetzt hier
drauf beim einem luxus menü hitze marie
ist dann sogar nicht nur ein getränk
sondern gleich zwei ja einmal bisschen
rosa auch abgelaufen am 16 17
unter noch eine smoothie 17
[Musik]
und auch die stellen werden
an die die sich fragen wie teuer das
ganze war also ich habe insgesamt für
die sachen die hier liegen drei euro
bezahlen also halt immer noch die hälfte
normalerweise werden sechs gewesen
sie biss hinaus wie kaiserschmarrn oder
aber ich finde es sehr gut was du
eigentlich muss ich ja selber
ausprobieren der teller placement okay
doch jetzt ist es sofort an der zeit
dass ich mal wurde mir das als wirklich
leckeres essen zu verkaufen und das
werde ich jetzt tun
mal schauen was sie sagt am besten
richten wir das erst am tisch
ja ich das sieht lecker aus
okay leute ich habe das immer wieder mal
so ein bisschen obst so ein bisschen
schön gemacht ich denke jetzt
wahrscheinlich what the [ __ ] wie sieht
das denn hier aus also das passt gar
nicht zusammen ich weiß aber dass da
habe ich mich ja selber übertroffen
kommen wie sie schön außer ob man noch
eine kerze es sieht nicht gut aus nur
ich frage mich warum so eingetreten
nein ich wollte immer kurz also ich habe
ja gesagt dass ich dir was leckeres zu
essen kochen und ich habe mir wirklich
wirklich richtig mühe gegeben und dir
sogar das essen kocht was du schon mal
gegessen hast auch ihren urlaub genießen
genau und
das jetzt mal probieren sogar mit zwei
getrennten da machst du da keine so
zugemacht weil die die soße die war
die gab es nicht
lass dir schmecken und das rennen wird
hier da würde ich diese seite empfehlen
da habe ich mir auch richtig mühe
gegeben aber irgendwo noch nix ja
entschuldigung
probier mal dass wir probleme richtig
noch ein bisschen mehr
[Musik]
man kannte ist nicht so schnell bekannt
ist nicht so schnell runterschlucken
stimmt andere sachen kann man schnell
und schmeckt ja echt lecker wurde
ok und jetzt wo wir noch mal lag hat
moody bist du selber war ja und das hier
auch nochmal
[Musik]
beträchtlich das hier ist mal ein
bisschen mehr
jetzt muss ich dir nämlich aussagen und
zwar alles was wir gerade probiert hast
war mindestens drei tage abgelaufen als
es noch tragen kann das toastbrot war
über zehn tage abgelaufen und der käse
drauf denn nur gerade gegessen hat der
war so hart dass er schon so dunkel geld
wurde aber es hat geschmeckt oder die
schmecken ganz gut und das kurspotenzial
könnte
das wollte ich nicht nur kurz sagen
jetzt kannst du mal wieder schlafen aber
man hat nicht gemerkt
heute und da haben wir das ergebnis das
abgelaufen nicht gleich schlecht heißt
mehr abgelaufenen lebensmitteln
das ist sehr wichtig um die moral von
der krankheit genau dann gibt's noch ein
update und die moral von der geschicht
was abgelaufen ist vergesst es nicht
[Musik]
das was mit dem video brauchen wir jeden
tag 19 video haut rein und